[Music]
early in your career you did some
television i did uh you did uh a monk an
episode of monk that that must have been
exciting for you that's a cool show it
was really exciting but it also was tied
to like the most humiliating thing in my
entire life when i was younger we went
to church every sunday when we first
moved to la cause my parents were like
meet some friends they just had no idea
what i would do with that opportunity of
friendship right when i um when
there was some announced like some girl
was like so for the monk episode there
was emily j and emily c i thought i was
gonna be playing emily c so this one
girl that's in the church goes i'm gonna
be playing emily j and monk i was like
oh my god i'm gonna be playing emily c
this is great and surfy's like oh we
can't wait to watch it find out i'm not
playing that part i am the mascot and so
everybody watched it after i just told
them that i was like gonna have this
great huge part and i was just the
mascot we actually never been back to
church since
you took the right lesson away
we found the clip of you on monk
you're now uh nominated for an academy
award let's see some of this fine work
that you did
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
you're giving it your all you don't
really really went for it yeah
i just imagine all your friends tuning
in you're like that was me
that was yeah i really thought i was
even lying about being the mascot no no
you can tell you can tell that's you uh
it's so you yeah silver linings playbook
i uh i loved this film as everyone has
but you are so terrific in the movie and
fearless just absolutely fearless and uh
and i told you backstage this i talked
about you after seeing the movie i
talked about you for i think about four
days until my wife said i think that's
enough
um but really such a brilliant
performance you took your parents to see
uh the movie in toronto is that right i
did yeah and i saw i'm sorry dad god
what what did you do you embarrassed
yourself yeah and i'm about to do it
again um because that's my favorite
thing to do but i
so we finished the
the movie and then we were outside and
then my dad walked out and he was crying
it was the first time i ever saw my dad
cry and instead of taking that moment in
i screamed at the top of my lungs dad
you're crying
and everybody's turned to look at him
but i swear it was because it was it
wasn't it had nothing to do with my
performance it's because at this
monologue with robert de niro afterwards
i pop a budweiser
and i think that that's what did it i
know i know my father and i know i was
watching that moment i was like he's
crying
why would why would that make him cry
the king of beers
that's just like our that's our beer and
i think i remember that being on the set
i was like god i can't wait for my dad
to see me drink a budweiser he's gonna
cry and he did that's true you give this
long great speech and then guess
budweiser and down and your dad's and my
dad
he got so emotional they have to be so
crazy proud though thank you yeah
they're proud they're mostly proud of my
taste of beer
you're going to get some free budweiser
now and yeah you wear that dad yeah
somewhere up there andy and i would like
our cut
we have a clip here from silver linings
playbook and i think this is a kind of a
it's a very emotional confrontational
uh scene that you have is that right
is it anything that we're about to look
at that's most of my scenes yeah do you
know which scene this is or you have no
idea
uh this is it outside the movie theater
this is when you steal a helicopter
this is outside the movie theater okay
yes that is highly emotional yeah highly
emotional are you ready yes i'm ready
are you ready let's take a look at this
clip from silver linings playbook
you may not have experienced that that i
did that you loved hearing about didn't
you
you are afraid to be alive you are
afraid to live you're a hypocrite you're
conformist you're a liar i opened up to
you and you judged me you are an [ __ ]
you are an [ __ ]
get off me get off your harassment
[Music]
[Applause]
is it hard for you to watch yourself or
you can do it
yeah i just like i annoy myself you
annoy yourself it's not like a weird
like acting thing i just like i'm just
like oh god
i well no one else feels that way let me
assure you and i i never i'm always
rolled polite and neutral about when it
comes to the oscars and we have guests
on but man am i rooting for you i just
think you're just i think you're the
best i think you're phenomenal yes